head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
all right let's get into this first
story and just uh let's roll with it
because you know we love the story NBC
News mysteriously pulls its exclusive
report on how Nancy Pelosi's husband
Paul calmly opened the door to cops in
his underpants and then walked towards
the hammer Intruder who bludgeoned him I
mean that's basically it they deleted
this video but okay we got it there's so
much to break down first the story was
an unknown third person opens the door
they walk in Paul Pelosi and this guy
are fighting over a hammer and the guy
gets it and hits him and then the cops
are like oh and they stop doing then the
story changes there's no third guy the
cops came in and saw them fighting then
the story changes again
now you've got Paul Pelosi opening the
door and calmly walking back to this guy
if he was really facing an intruder or
being threatened he would have walked
out he would have opened the door if the
cops and said please officer that's the
guy and he would have walked with the
cops not away from the cops so the
question is did NBC News delete this
report because this report was fake news
or was there other reporting fake news
and this is the real news I don't know
NBC said for the record specifically by
the way it matters here what they said
in this report that's now deleted and
people can't find other than of course
the saved videos that are being shared
on social media but they said
specifically that Paul Pelosi quote did
not immediately declare an emergency or
tried to leave his home but instead
began walking several feet back into the
foyer towards the assailant there's also
reports from that NBC program that this
was something that was going on for over
30 minutes again they why can't they get
their story straight here why did they
delete this what is really going on here
and the people who are asking questions
were right all along but but this is
this gets even deeper because NBC just
released another article another report
and the headline of it is quote the GOP
has Paul Pelosi's blood on his hands I
mean come on I mean just when you're
trying to manipulate an event for your
own personal political benefit now we
have such outrageous lies and confusion
and and so many different versions of
events here what's going on I disagree I
think this is just as bad as 9 11. this
is racist not alive no no no even worse
this is worse than January 6th
and January 6th and Pearl Harbor look
who hasn't been caught wrestling on the
floor with some guy in his underwear and
a hammer when his wife's not home in his
house like if that hasn't happened to
you like you can throw the first stone
okay yeah but now they're saying the guy
wasn't in his underpants right why yeah
look they said he was in his underpants
they say he was in his underpants and
then they found zip ties and then people
went where did he put the zip ties and
they went uh he had a backpack they're
like so he had a backpack in his
underpants okay okay well he wasn't in
his eyes okay
no I mean release the cameras they have
cameras they won't release them this
this all could end if they release the
footage and the fact that they won't I
think says something what it says I
don't know but I mean you can go back to
the 9-1-1 call and what does Paul Pelosi
say his name is David and he's my friend
he says I don't well he didn't say that
the cop is reporting what he heard right
and so he's the cop is like he says he
doesn't know the male but his name is
David and he's a friend and he's gonna
wait for his wife that's right now that
it makes sense that the story was Paul
dialed 9-1-1 without letting the dude
know and then was talking loudly in code
saying something like I don't know you
and the guy was probably like don't
worry I'm a friend I want to talk to
Nancy I wonder if the real story was
this guy is a leftist he's got BLM in
his window he's got a pride flag he
lives with Berkeley hemp hippies I
wonder if he was like I need to talk to
Nancy like she's gonna help me do you
remember when that guy climbed Trump
Tower and he said I need to talk to
Trump he was a supporter he wasn't a he
wasn't a hater I wonder if that's what
happened and then when when Pelosi calls
the cops he's thinking like everything's
fine and then the dude ends up hitting
him or something maybe he pretends hold
on I got another story for you
what if
the police
hit Paul Pelosi
what if what really happened is Paul did
call the cops no no don't hear me out
what if Paul called the cops and the
cops Russian freaking out break the
glass kick the door in and then see Paul
in his underwear hit him knock him down
and then go oh crap that was the
homeowner and hold on that would explain
why they said the Intruder was in his
underwear it was an unknown man who
answered the door and now they're
changing their story he could have been
drunk and Rowdy and out of control and
they would they were like hey bringing
the hobo down the street we got to blame
this on somebody but but who knows what
happened here too hey yeah yeah that's
what a possibility here well so you know
what if no and and maybe they brought
him I don't know I don't get two
conspiratorial but what if Paul does
call the cops and when he sees the cops
he runs to the door yelling or doing
something frantic and the cops just boom
right in the face I wouldn't necessarily
blame the cops like it's a bad thing if
the cops just struck a guy but if you
get a call as a home Intruder and
there's a there's a crazy man in my
house and then you walk up and you see a
dude and his underwear where coming
towards you frantic and yelling the cops
are gonna be like back up and they're
gonna hit you they put the guy down they
Paul Pelosi goes down hits his head and
they go oh crap could we get our story
straight could we play the NBC report
because it was very terrible I don't
know if we have it it's all over social
media it's all over Twitter I tweeted it
out yeah
but but they also reported that the
police officers didn't know the severity
of the situation didn't know that it was
uh Paul Pelosi and that's again just
extremely unlike he's arrived here at
the Pelosi home exactly a week ago today
they initially didn't have any idea
exactly what was going on they knew they
had a high priority call on their hand
what was unclear what was happening
inside the property just behind me
this morning Paul Pelosi is home back at
the house that became a crime scene a
week ago today NBC News learning new
details about the moments police arrived
sources familiar with what unfolded in
the Pelosi residence now revealing when
officers responded to the high priority
call they were seemingly unaware they've
been called to the home of the Speaker
of the House how after a knock and
announce the front door was opened by Mr
Pelosi the 82 year old did not
immediately declare an emergency or
tried to leave his home why but instead
began walking several feet back into the
foyer toward the assailant and away from
police it's unclear if the 82 year old
was already injured or what his mental
state was say sources according to court
documents when the officer asked what
was going on defendant smiled and said
everything's good but instantaneously a
struggle ensued as police clearly saw
saw David depap strike Paul Pelosi in
the head with a hammer after tackling
the suspect officers rushed to Mr Pelosi
who was lying in a pool of blood what we
do know is he brutally attacked Mr
Pelosi and attempted to kill him after
spending several several days in the ICU
Pelosi who is recovering from a
fractured skull in serious injuries to
his arm and hand is now home where
Capitol Police remain on alert
investigators have previously said
Pelosi did not know to Pap when the 42
year old broke into his home how did
they know why Pelosi didn't try to flee
or tell responding officers he was in
distress is unclear fear all right let's
pause real quick there is zero
confirmation that broke into the house
right this is between Pelosi and the pap
the perhaps pleaded not guilty there is
a statement he gave and so what I mean
to say is I'll clarify there is
circumstantial evidence he broke into
the house a lot of it I'm saying is
we've not seen hard evidence the story
is as they claim we've not seen videos
we've not seen like third parties we
just have the two people involved saying
here's what happened and then the cops
changing their story 50 times so I think
it's fair to say why did NBC delete this
video maybe the reporter was lying maybe
the reporter was wrong if you come to me
and said hey Tim this reporter lied I
would say is it a day ending in why so
then someone says yo pull that story
this isn't true I'd be like not
surprising now hold on hold on that
being said
deleting the video itself could be them
trying to manipulate and cover up so if
you told me they deleted the video
because it was true I'd say is it a day
ending and why so I'm not going to sit
here and Trust NBC but their their
report was predominantly based on the
police reports and interviews they did
with the police so the burden of proof
is not on on NBC here it's on the police
officers who are trying to tell you
there's no way the two knew each other
how do you know that were they following
and spying on these two people uh for
for their whole lives again that that
doesn't make sense and another aspect
here that doesn't make sense is this
this suspect that broke into the home
was allegedly a mastermind uh Q Maga guy
who's going to Target Pelosi and go
after her saw the cops and then that's
the moment he decided to take a hammer
and strike Paul that does that doesn't
make sense I don't know how this sounds
but I actually don't care a whole lot
about this incident in the details of it
and what I care more about is the fact
that it was propagandized as a kind of
as an example of deliberate methodical
right-wing violence attempt to
assassinate a Democrat by some Q Anon
Trump supporting person when just
everything we know about like the basic
facts of it say that that's that's not
true and at the same time that that's
happening you know Bill Maher does a
whole segment that this is a
continuation of the Cold War right this
is the Cold War in the United States
heating up he does this whole monologue
it's just absurd right yeah and as
that's happening you have a GOP
candidate I think his name is Pat
Harrigan uh whose house was was fired at
uh this happened in the last 24 hours
police kids almost died police confirmed
that someone shot uh into uh the home
where his parents live and I think his
kids were in the house at the time
and that's that's just one example right
like over the summer uh uh lee zeldin
was attacked and I think there's there's
other recent examples of Republican
politicians who are being attacked and
in some it's obviously difficult to find
like are these people actually uh
Democrats or what are they I think and
there's one politician who was attacked
by what the media characterized as a
Libertarian activist but we don't know
that right but the point is is that
there is a disproportionate amount of
violence that I think obviously comes
more from the left but where the
difference is is in the coverage
I don't believe
your average Maga person gets violent
like I say on average there's outliers
of course but you hear these stories
where Bill Maher says the danger of the
right wing yeah and then it turns out to
be these Jesse smallett incidents yes
but the media always reports it as
though the right cause the problem so an
example is I was in Portland proud boys
were marching antifa started a counter
protest
the proud boys were minding their own
business and walking around the American
flags antifa was antagonizing and
screaming racial slurs did the media
come out and say a peaceful march by
conservatives was attacked by anti of
course not they said you know violent
right-wing group shows up and clashes
with antifa or whatever but that wasn't
the reality of what happened that's
right we saw that a whole lot the proud
boys would go somewhere or not even the
proud boys like right-wing groups
conservative groups would march with
flags and then all of a sudden Andy
would jump and get into fights and the
media would say it was either mutual
combat or violent right-wingers showed
up and then you see what happens in in
New York
the mistake made by the conservatives
when antifa came and showed up to a
Gavin McGinnis our proud boys or it was
again a speaking event and started
throwing things at people and basically
surrounding the outer blocks
proud boys run full speed at him get
into a fight start bragging about what
they were doing and how they fought and
it was all live streamed when the police
arrested them
well the good cop love and right Wingers
said sure officer I'll tell you
everything and antifa pulled their masks
up and ran full speed and refused to
give statements the antifa guys no
charges why don't know who they are the
proud boys they're in prison that's how
it works yep back to Blue right thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time